I'd like to show you how to neutralize
the bad effects from caffeine now I am
going to go through the positives of
consuming caffeine and I'm talking
mainly about coffee and tea not sodas
and also some of the cons some of the
negatives okay and there are negatives
and I will say that coffee is very very
addicting and I'll be the first to admit
that I am addicted to coffee and I am
not going to give it up now I can still
control the amount of coffee I drink I
just have two shots of espresso every
morning okay with a little cream and one
packet of Xylitol I don't do any more
than that and even though there are some
negative things I'm going to show you
what to do to get rid of those negative
things but there is also some positive
things too if you don't consume too much
now there's some very interesting things
about the caffeine in coffee okay people
think that it gives them energy right
well there's no energy in coffee that
you're going to get when you drink it
it basically manipulates certain
chemicals that are already in your body
and one of the chemicals that caffeine
affects is adenosine that's a certain
chemical in the body that does a lot of
different things
um it's part of the ATP the energy
source of your body adenosine
transphosphate it's also makes up your
DNA but it has another function of
helping you sleep and so this chemical
compound caffeine mimics or looks very
very close to
adenosine and so what happens is
caffeine acts like a key and goes into
the receptors for adenosine okay and it
locks it up it blocks it so if someone
sticks some key that doesn't quite fit
into a lock and then it's jammed you
can't open that door so now adenosine
doesn't really work to a certain degree
and so now you don't get asleepy okay so
that's one effect of caffeine it gets
rid of this compound that makes you
sleepy but for me when I drink coffee it
become very creative I have better
cognitive skills sharper I have better
ideas things like that and that is
because caffeine stimulates another
compound called
acetylcholine acetylcholine is necessary
for the central nervous system for
different things in the brain and it's
considered a neurotransmitter because it
helps messages travel through the brain
and so it's related to feeling awake
helping with your attention memory every
learning
cognitive function and then the third
thing that caffeine does is it increases
nor adrenaline that is the
neurotransmitter that is triggered when
you're awake and so serotonin melatonin
helps you with sleep but no adrenaline
keeps you awake and caffeine stimulates
your adrenaline and noradrenaline is
also involved in keeping you focused as
well as learning and has some very
similar things to acetylcholine so
that's what capping does okay now let's
first talk about the the good things
about caffeine what it can do for you
number one it can help lower the risk of
dementia okay that's pretty cool it can
help you with gallstones it can help you
with the fatty liver it can help you
decrease
fibrosis within the liver it can even
help lower liver enzymes adding fat to
your coffee in the morning can help you
fast for a longer period of time which
can help you get into the keto adapted
State and of course drinking coffee can
help you with these
temporary cognitive benefits right
because for me it probably lasts several
hours and then it's like it's over but
of course in the past in college I would
keep drinking coffee to the entire day I
mean I would drink pots and pots of
coffee and that was a very bad thing but
at first I could handle it but then I
couldn't handle it now the cons or the
negatives of caffeine okay are this it
can increase blood pressure it can
increase cholesterol
it has a potential to cause insomnia it
can increase cortisol it can also
increase adrenaline you know and maybe a
little bit is okay but if you overdo it
that can kind of affect your adrenals it
can give you uh anxiety it can give you
depression as a side effect it can
actually make you tired it can cause
arrhythmias it can give you a headache
it can give you a panic attack it can
cause mood swings it can give you neck
tension okay jaw tightness as well as
grinding your teeth at night it can also
cause a B1 deficiency which can cause
more nervous tension or stress and it
can also act as a diuretic okay you can
lose electrolytes as well now a lot of
these negative effects occur more with
people
who have kind of a genetic variation
with the detoxification of caffeine now
if you're watching this and you have a
problem with drinking too much coffee or
just being exposed to too much caffeine
you already know you have a problem with
it okay and so this video can help you
but that being said if you don't have a
problem with coffee I'm going to give
you some things to do to kind of help
detoxify this caffeine from your liver
more thoroughly but if you have a
genetic variant to this enzyme that is
supposed to help you detoxify caffeine
this could lower your ability to get rid
of caffeine by 40x okay and so caffeine
just stays in your body longer and
creates more damage but not only
caffeine estrogen
smoking drugs medications so in general
these toxins stay in your body longer so
again what I'm going to tell you will
not only help you clear out of caffeine
but will also help you clear out some of
these other poisons as well so the first
tip I'm going to give you is just to
lessen your exposure to caffeine okay
and coffee and whenever else caffeine is
in like tea chocolate things like that
and of course soft drinks is a given so
that's one thing I did I just have one
cup which two shots of espresso in the
morning that's it I don't consume any
more than that and that can actually
help you and also the obvious thing is
to minimize the exposure to like I said
the drugs the estrogen the chemicals
ETC number two exercise that can greatly
help you as well the more heavy exercise
you do the more you can get rid of these
toxins okay so that's number two number
three and if you guess cruciferous you
are correct like broccoli broccoli
Sprouts
cauliflower
radish arugula now two of the foods that
will also help someone detoxify caffeine
is celery and parsley so if you include
that in your diet that would be a very
good thing and the last thing that is
just the super Powerhouse of
detoxification is curcumin and that
would be in turmeric so if you're
suffering from the negative things from
coffee or caffeine I just gave you
several things to do to help minimize
the damage now since we're on the topic
of coffee if you have not seen my video
on Bulletproof Coffee
that's been a very popular one I put it
up right here check it out